Oregon Washington and Idaho as you'll
probably know are not a part of Canada
they were admitted as states to the USA
in the latter half of the 19th century
despite being claimed by the British the
Russians and also the Spanish for
centuries before this Russia and Spain
didn't press their claims for very long
which left only the British who in 1846
agreed to cede these lands to the United
States in return for exactly nothing
which raises the obvious question why
why did Britain hand over this land to
the United States so to begin after the
Americans politely asked the British to
stop running their country the two had
to find a way to get along Westward
Expansion by Beaufort to both claiming
the same lands on the Pacific coast and
after the war of 1812 was concluded both
sides wanted to settle their territory
or disputes to prevent a future War this
led to the 1818 agreement in which
Britain agreed to cede these lands to
the United States in return for the U.S
handing these to Britain along the 49th
parallel The Hope in Washington was that
this line would continue all the way to
the Pacific Ocean however Britain
refused because they didn't want to lose
access to the Columbia river which it
used for exports as search it was agreed
that Britain and the United States would
consolidate both of their claims and
place them under joint rule the
Americans called This Land the Oregon
Country whereas the British called it
the Columbia territory this created some
problems the first was that both Russia
and Spain claimed the land the Russians
were soon brought off by both the
British and the Americans and in 1819
the Spanish gave their claim to the
United States as a part of a land
transfer the second issue was that
neither side were happy and thus wanted
to undermine the other the British
wanted to make the territory valueless
to the United States by sending Trappers
and paying natives there to overhunt so
the Americans couldn't make a living
which the government hoped would lead to
the United States just handing the
territory over in response the Americans
sent people lots of people who would tip
the balance of the population in the
United States favor and forced Britain
to settle the American approach worked
and in the early 1840s the Americans
living there demanded that the US
government do something about the shared
control of Oregon presidential candidate
and later winner James K Polk campaigned
and won on taking all of the territory
and when he went off as he told the
British government that join control of
the territory no longer worked for the
United States and he assumed that London
would simply back down instead the Royal
Navy was mustered and so soon after the
American government asked that the
British government should simply just
make them an offer and the British
basically gave in to all of America's
demands and mostly gave them what they'd
asked for in 1818. now this wasn't an
easy decision for Britain to make and
there were many there who believed that
the United States was bluffing as
negotiations were ongoing war broke out
between the United States and its
Southern neighbor and for some in
Britain this presented an opportunity
two front Wars are not very fun and so
there were some that wanted to make
greater demands of the United States in
return for not aiding Mexico prime
minister peel however didn't want war
and he was simply interested in dealing
with all of Britain's foreign policy
squabbles this was so he could focus on
repealing the Corn Laws at home and
allowing the free importer food into the
UK particularly Ireland peel and his
colleagues knew that doing this would be
the end of their political careers and
so they used this as leverage to get
Polk to accept Britain's offer since if
the Americans pushed for too much land
they just have to renegotiate with
whoever followed peel as such Britain
agreed to cede all of this to the United
States barring Vancouver Island for the
British government of the time handing
over territory of little economic value
in return for peace with a major trading
partner so that more pressing concerns
could be dealt with seemed obvious
whereas for the United States the land
that they gained was arable which was
ultimately what they wanted and there
was little to be gained from pushing All
the Way North to the border of Russian
America since it's not like they had any
interests there I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonet Kelly moneymaker
course show wolf Sky Chappelle kotoitska
Alex Schwinn Jerry Lambton Jordan
Longley Adams daughter rod D Martin
Marcus arsner AF Firefly Y and hockey
Captain psydog Spencer Lightfoot Miss
izet boogly Wiggly Marvin Casa Winston
caywood Daniel to be in commun Aaron the
white Gustav Swann the mcwhopper words
about books podcast she went in spinning
three plates Maggie baskowski Anthony
Beckett Coppertone and Charles the first